bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
le pianiste de jazz michel petrucciani
est décédé à l'âge de 36 ans à new york
sa virtuosité sa volonté lui avait fait
oublier son grave handicap
lionel jospin évoque point par point la
politique qu'il entend suivre dans les
mois à venir dans le journal de mon
guide réplique aux dernières
interventions de jacques chirac
la mère est en danger les hommes s'en
sert comme une poubelle l'état de la
méditerranée est alarmant en grande
bretagne les hôpitaux publics confrontés
une épidémie de grippe révèle de très
graves dysfonctionnements c'est tout
système de santé public en le mec est
encombré pourquoi pas moi c'est le titre
du film de stéphane giusti comédie sur
la tolérance et la différence sexuelle
deux des interprètes julie gayet johnny
hallyday sans nous inviter pianiste
compositeur de jazz célébré en europe
comme aux états unis michel petrucciani
était qualifié de virtuoses de génie on
l'écoutait passionnément découvrant
ainsi que cet homme lourdement handicapé
par une maladie qui avait bloqué sa
croissance et est capable avec son piano
de nous faire rêver nous fait rêver en
musique
michel petrucciani avait 36 ans il est
mort subitement dans un hôpital de new
york des suites d'une infection
pulmonaire
qu'il jonglait avec les notes comme si
le jazz n'avait pour lui aucun secret
michel petrucciani a appris le piano
alors qu'il savait à peine écrire à
l'âge de 12 ans il fait son premier
conseil il avait une technique unique au
monde
explications on va prendre des mois
bon alors on part de là alors on peut
faire la mélodie dont peut varier la
mélodie en changeant les drames et alors
par exemple et après on peut changer les
harmonies et mettre encore plus de
choses au milieu brodier encore plus
donc ça peut être
michel petrucciani le premier pianiste
français avoir su s'imposer aux états
unis il enchaîne les succès sans que
jamais sa maladie ne soit pour lui un
handicap
il trouvait son inspiration lorsqu'il
jouer en duo
chaque fois que j'ai pu jouer avec
michel petrucciani ça a été un immense
plaisir parce qu'il y avait justement
cette cette humilité cette simplicité et
surtout cette oreille tout à fait
particulière qu'il prêtait à l'autre et
j'avais a toujours l'impression cette
image qu'on se retrouvait souvent du mot
parce qu'on jouait temps en temps diot
de deux autres comme si on se retrouvait
sur dans un bac à sable tous les deux et
qu'on faisait des pâtes et c'était aussi
simple que cela
dernier message de michel petrucciani à
son ami bernard maury on est le même
jour que nous étions conscients qu'ils
avaient durable dans sa vie que
malheureusement des personnes qui sont
atteintes d'un handicap qui l'avait ont
une espérance de vie relativement limité
et il voulait c'est quelque chose à le
mini pense ne voulait pas y penser
maintenant entend effectivement seule
vente et voilà
michel petrucciani a reçu toutes les
récompenses qu un jazzman pouvait
recevoir mais son plus grand succès est
sans doute d'avoir su transmettre
l'amour du jazz au plus grand nombre et
à cette évocation préparé par frédéric
bonnet bernard ronfler j'ajoute les
hommages de jacques chirac qui part d'un
génie musical de lionel jospin qui
rappelle les grandes émotions
esthétiques et le véritable talent de
michel petrucciani et puis de dominique
wallon directeur national de la musique
qui estime que michel petrucciani avait
porté au plus haut l'art de
l'improvisation de la rencontre et du
plaisir de jouer
c'est dans le journal le monde que le
premier ministre lionel jospin ouvre son
année politique il s'explique point par
point sur les différents aspects du
programme gouvernemental qu'il entend
conduire en estimant nous avons
construit davantage que nous ne nous
sommes usés depuis 19 mois alors voici
en détail les principaux éléments de
l'entretien accordé par lionel jospin au
journal le monde
avec le commentaire de françoise david
la trêve des confiseurs et bien finie
c'est aujourd'hui dans le journal le
monde que lionel jospin met le cap sur
l'an 2000 en définissant ses grandes
priorités violences dans les banlieues
augmentation de la délinquance des
mineurs
le premier ministre affirme que la lutte
contre l'insécurité sera après l'emploi
la deuxième priorité de l'année 1999
il faut dit-il notamment développer la
police de proximité
lionel jospin table toujours sur une
augmentation de la croissance et il veut
en faire profiter les français non
seulement nous n'entendons pas augmenter
les prélèvements obligatoires
mais nous souhaitons continuer à les
abaisser tout en renforçant encore la
justice fiscale et sociale
les sans papiers qui ne répondent pas
aux critères de régularisations doivent
quitter le territoire indique par
ailleurs le premier ministre
nous nous tiendrons à cette politique
respectueuse de la dignité de la
personne et de l'état de droit
la multiplication de listes à gauche
pour les élections européennes ne paraît
pas inquiété le chef du gouvernement
pour moi les élections européennes ne
sont pas un problème mais simplement un
rendez vous démocratique note il en
précisant que françois hollande ferait
une excellente tête de liste enfin
interrogé sur les discours de jacques
chirac lionel jospin juge qui n'ont pas
le même caractère quand le président est
l'inspirateur de la politique comme il a
été entre 1995 et 1997
et quand il ne l'est plus ils n'ont pas
non plus la même signification
selon qu'ils s'expriment pro nom de tous
les français ou pour l'opposition
voilà gérard leclerc c'est un départ en
fanfare pour 99 de monsieur respect
absolument lionel jospin reprend la main
d'abord face à jacques chirac qui
multiplie les piques contre le
gouvernement le premier ministre
réplique tantôt vertement tantôt avec un
zeste de condescendance 0 ni en résumé
le président parle mais c'est le
gouvernement qui agit il est peut-être
mettre des échéances électorales mais
pas de leurs résultats
elle lui ions à peine voilée à la
dissolution ratée il lui arrive de
s'exprimer comme chef de l'opposition
enfin le premier ministre empiète
légèrement sur les plates bandes du
domaine réservé du président en
soulignant la coloration nouvel imprimé
par le gouvernement à la politique
étranger alors voilà pour l'adresse à
l'elysée mais maintenant face au
français monsieur jospin avait un
certain nombre de choses a alors dit
will l'automne avait pu laisser à
l'opinion un sentiment
flottement voire de cafouillages des
jasmins contre attaque d'une part en
assurant sur la foi des sondages que le
gouvernement n'est pas usé et qu'il a
obtenu des résultats tangibles face au
chômage sur les 35 heures ou sur le
pouvoir d'achat
d'autre part en affichant clairement des
priorités volontarisme pour l'emploi
celui des jeunes notamment et fermeté
sur les sécurités dans un registre super
chevènementiste il faut par exemple
s'attaquer au phénomène des bandes sans
admettre les excuses sociologique à la
verse le gouvernement ne doit plus se
disperser moins de loi au parlement et
des replis prévisible sur certains
projets comme l'audiovisuel par exemple
alors ce soir si le rpr se dit accablé
des jérémiades du premier ministre
l'elysée joue la sérénité
le président continuera fonction oblige
nous dit-on à s'exprimer au nom de
l'intérêt des français
avec encore tout à l'heure il ya
quelques minutes une mise en garde sur
la politique de défense bref la
cohabitation suit son cours une
cohabitation virer comolli en rugby
là vous pariez de l'accablement du rpr
c'était à propos du référence des propos
du premier ni sur le rôle du président
la république
et puis en fin d'après midi monsieur
jospin réunissait des ministres
concernés par le projet de réforme de
l'audiovisuel
mais traduisant bien l'embarras du
gouvernement il paraît qu'un proche de
soins dits cette réunion doit répondre à
trois questions est ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'en fait-on
réponse à venir madame trautmann qui
vient de sortir de la réunion dit que
l'objectif de la réforme audiovisuelle
et mappy et puis deux sondages ils
concernent jacques chirac et lionel
jospin et il s'agit déjà de répondre à
la question des présidentielles plus de
trois ans avant la date des sondages
donnent six points d'avancé à jacques
chirac pour l'ifop et deux points
d'avance toujours à jacques chirac pour
csa sondages publiés respectivement par
l'express et l'événement je dis bien un
événement c'est plus l'événement du
jeudi car d'événements chance son format
et son aspect le droit à la sécurité
figurent parmi les priorités réaffirmée
par le premier ministre et plusieurs
fois répété par le président de
république dans les différentes
cérémonies de voeux actuelle et les
chiffres de la délinquance en hausse sur
les onze premiers mois de l'année 98
sont venus confirmer le sentiment
général qu'il était urgent d'améliorer
la lutte contre l'insécurité et la
délinquance avec un soin particulier
concernant les actes de violences commis
par les mineurs commentaires olivier
kempf
la sécurité priorité du gouvernement
lionel jospin l'a réaffirmé aujourd'hui
2,7 pour cent de crimes et délits en
plus de janvier à novembre 98 et une
fois sur cinq un auteur âgé de moins de
18 ans les chiffres sont mauvais jean
pierre chevènement relance le débat j'ai
dit qu'il fallait se donner les moyens
d'éloigner un certain nombre de jeunes
multirécidivistes qui ont 40 réfraction
à leur actif et avant saison et on ne
peut rien contre eux aujourd'hui il faut
se donner les moyens de les éloigner des
quartiers qu'ils ont mis en coupe réglée
je crois que ça fait partie de la
recontre américaine des banlieues à
bobigny dans l'un des plus importants
tribunaux pour enfants de france on ne
se dit pas si désarmés que cela dont il
se dit qu'on n'a aucun moyen à l'égard
de ces jeunes ils se trompent
vous savez qu'on peut condamner un jeune
qui a plus de 13 ans et on ne manque pas
de condamner des jeunes qui ont 13 14 15
ans pour les faits délictueux ou
criminels qu'ils ont pu commettre et
mais pas seulement criminelle
deuxièmement c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
les incarcérer titre provisoire
là si on pouvait au moins les mettre
sous contrôle judiciaire
et si le comte roger tirs étaient violés
être sanctionné ça serait une bonne
avancée il y a un an et demi jean pierre
chevènement suggéré lui la réouverture
des maisons de redressement
elisabeth guigou s'y était opposé
enfermement ou éducation à bobigny on a
choisi sur la base d'expériences pilotes
l'expérience démontre que par les
mesures qui sont prises par la
remobilisation parental dans les
discussions de sont prises à l'elysée à
victime exerçait mesures de réparation
être scolarisés on n'a pas plus de 7% de
récidive une méthode qui réclame
d'importants moyens financiers et
humains
plus modestement le gouvernement
pourrait envisager une réforme de
l'ordonnancé de 45 sur les mineurs
un texte déjà modifié plus de 20 fois en
un demi siècle alors souvent à l'origine
de ces violences urbaines il y à des
situations sociales économiques très
difficiles aussi à la fin de l'année 96
le gouvernement de monsieur alain juppé
avait t-il créer des zones franches
doter de mesures fiscales dérogatoires
pour favoriser l'emploi et l'activité
économique 44 zone avait été ainsi créés
en métropole et dans les départements
d'outre-mer
mais aujourd'hui un rapport de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales dresse un premier bilan et
estiment peu efficace pour l'emploi ce
dispositif des zones franches
explications avec laurent bailly entre
bordeaux et sa zone franche la plus
grande de france juste la garonne a
franchit ici en deux ans les entreprises
ont poussé comme des champignons 173
rien que pour cette petite commune de
cenon et pour cause le statut de zone
franche leur permet de ne payer aucun
impôt est presque aucune charge sociale
en échange de ce mini paradis fiscal
certaines sociétés comme ici où l'on
vend un peu de tout par téléphone ont
joué le jeu et embaucher des jeunes sur
place même si l'on trouve toujours une
bonne raison pour ne pas embaucher
davantage
c'est la grosse difficulté pour les
entreprises qui arrivent s'est retrouvé
là au delà d'une école une même oeuvre
qualifiée
vrai ou faux en tout cas les quarante
quatre zones franches implantés un peu
partout en france par alain juppé alors
premier ministre n'ont créé que 10000
emplois dans les banlieues difficiles
alors qu'elles ont coûté plus d'un
milliard et demi à l'état aujourd'hui
des rapports des inspections des
finances et des affaires sociales
dénonce ce système qui a profité à de
nombreuses entreprises sans développer
de réelles activités en échange dans ces
documents confidentiels on parle même d'
effets pervers les
localisation un phénomène de chasseurs
de primes
et puis finalement un système qui a plus
profité aux entreprises ou aux
professions libérales qu'il n'a permis
réellement la création d'emplois donc à
la fois il va falloir respecter la
parole de l'état ne va falloir réaliser
le système mais en dépit des dérives
constatées le système des zones franches
continue de trouver d'ardents défenseurs
moi je ne connais pas de système fiscal
qui n'est pas quelques dérives à la
marge je fais confiance au gouvernement
pour y mettre bon ordre si tel était le
cas en tout cas ce qu'on constate nous
c'est qu'il essaie famille l'entreprise
nouvelle implantées dans les zones
franches ont créé dix mille emplois et
que ça c'est une réalité que ce sont des
emplois pérennes ce ne sont pas des
empereurs elle public ce sont des
emplois privés je ne crois pas qu'elle
critique que l'on peut formuler que ce
soit un peu cher évidemment pour les
banlieues en difficultés et afin qu'elle
n'explose pas il fallait bien y mettre
les moyens nécessaires j'attends de voir
ce que le gouvernement va mettre comme
moyen supplémentaire car il en faut dans
les mois qui viennent le gouvernement
réformera le système pour qu'à l'avenir
il bénéficie avant tout aux demandeurs
d'emploi des quartiers difficiles report
de la date limite de dépôt des
déclarations de revenus initialement
c'était le lundi 1er mars la limite a
été repoussée au lundi 15 mars à minuit
la mer devient petit à petit une
poubelle commode pour les hommes ce
matin le journal la provence s'appuyant
sur un rapport de l'ifremer institut
français de recherche pour
l'exploitation de la mer cite l exemple
de la méditerranée les débris les
plastiques les déchets en tout genre que
nous jetons à la mer transforme peu à
peu les fonds marins en une gigantesque
décharge
reportage aux est bien la pierre et
jacques devaux une seconde pour s'en
débarrasser des dizaines d'années pour
effacer leurs traces
car ici entre toulon et marseille par
200 à 600 mètres de fond
la mer n'est pas près d'oublier ce que
l'homme a jeté par dessus bord mais
aussi abandonné dans les décharges
la mer est une poubelle on s'en doutait
aujourd'hui l'ifremer nous en donne la
preuve après six ans de campagne
effectuée dans toutes les mers d'europe
principales techniques
le chalutage est tout simplement le
comptage
d'après les premiers résultats la
méditerranée est la plus touchée
on a commencé les travaux on imaginer
que rentrer ouvrez simplement autour des
grandes villes est très à la côte et
dans la réalité fut on est des pros font
plus on l'a trouvé en particulier en
méditerranée et avec une extension qui
peut aller très très moyen largement
qu'effectivement on a été assez surpris
et qui plus est la sensation dans la
sous- marin c'est justement que des
millions de personnes qui vivent à terre
et qui font fi de ce qui se passe au
fond de la mer et que ça sert un petit
peu de récepteurs des déchets qui se
comptent par millions 50 au fond du
golfe de gascogne 150 en mer du nord 40
pour l'adriatique
enfin 300 millions de dhs et rictus
immergé en méditerranée parmi eux une
majorité de plastique 60 à 95 % d'après
ce chercheur qui a réalisé une première
le risque selon lui c'est d'abord
l'étranglement des organismes marins
mais aussi une perte économique pour les
pêcheurs obligé de faire le tri dans
leurs filets enfin une insécurité pour
l'ensemble des marques carlier aussi
tout ce qui flotte 750 millions d'objets
ont été trouvés à la surface de la
méditerranée le monde du silence est
menacée le commandant cousteau n'avait
cessé de le dire
c'était bourré de quoi sont la vie était
intense là la flore était intense
également la question est très grave
l allure méditerranée lie aux caraïbes
etc d'autres recherches de l'ifremer à
plus grande profondeur encore doivent
être entreprises afin de mieux évaluer
l'origine des pollutions et tenter d'y
remédier et pour compléter ce rapport de
l'ifremer voici maintenant l'exemple des
bords de la méditerranée c'est entre
cagnes sur mer et en titre que nous
sommes allés des associations des élus
locaux tentent de limiter les dégâts
mais chaque jour
les pêcheurs peuvent constater dans
leurs filets que la mer est bien
toujours une poubelle
reportage yasmina farber et fabrique des
sans les pêcheurs vivent au quotidien la
pollution de la méditerranée dans leurs
filets ils ramènent toujours des
poissons mais aussi de plus en plus de
détritus ce souvent les souvenirs de
vacances des plaisanciers pour la fête
et bobino bouteille de champagne au lieu
de la mettre dans un sac fois allongé
bouteilles de bière jette dans les ports
les plaisanciers sont pourtant informés
sensibilisés mais ils ne sont pas les
seuls responsables
la côte d'azur reçoit beaucoup de
déchets venus d'italie ramené par le
courant ligure
les autorités sont mobilisés en était un
avion du conseil général traque les
nappe de pollution
une armée de bateaux pélican ramasse les
objets flottants chaque commune a un
plan d'action pour protéger le littoral
son bassin touristique
la côte d'azur sans une une mer
méditerranée parfaite perd tout son être
capacité touristique qui fait son avenir
économique
un relate plastique une deux trois
quatre fils de petit chose d'extérieur
sensibiliser c'est le rôle des
associations certaines opérations de
nettoyage des fonds marins tout près des
plages laisse songeur malgré tout les
protecteurs de l'environnement ne
s'avoue pas vaincue par la pollution
il faut pas laisser croire que la
méditerranée est morte
la méditerranée n'est pas une poubelle
j'y tiens beaucoup parce que comme il
faut la protéger en nue-propriété on ne
protège pas des poubelles donc c'est pas
la peine de te à traiter de poubelles et
la rayer de la carte des mers
récupérables les poches de pollution
existe sur la côte d'azur mais la faune
sous-marine résiste bien
les dauphins ne vous de même pas les
hommes qui salissent leur terrain de jeu
demain l'élection à la présidence de la
région rhône alpes sera très discutée
l'issue est incertaine à l'extrême
droite au front national il ya déjà deux
candidats dont monsieur gauche miss et
si à gauche
jean-jack queyranne et le candidat
unique à droite le président sortant
charmilles on doit toujours compter sur
les voix des élus du front national s'il
veut revenir s'asseoir dans le fauteuil
de la présidence ronald monsieur
millions qu'une équipe de france 2 avec
benoît gallerey philippe rivet a suivi
durant cette journée de veille
d'élections affiche sa sérénité depuis
l'invalidation de son élection à la
présidence de région
charles millon n'est plus qu'un simple
conseiller régional demain ils comptent
mettre fin à cette parenthèse en
retrouvant son siège l'élection paraît
incertaine mais lui qui se qualifie de
paysans du budget un paysan opiniâtre
paraît ne pas douter
qui peut ressortir des urnes m
j'espère la fidélité à l'électorat la
démocratie c'est sa confiance je suis
sort à neuf mois de troubles de
condamnations des états majors
politiques on tuerait ce don d'une
partie de ses troupes il ne serait plus
qu'une quarantaine de fidèles sur 157
conseillers sans le front national dont
la position ce soir n'est toujours pas
arrêtée charles millon ne peut être
réélu toutes les voix qui approuve mon
projet ou qui préfèrent le projet que
j'ai présenté aux électeurs qui étaient
approuvés par les rhônalpins qui
préfèrent ce projet là à d'autres
projets aujourd'hui on ne connaît pas
d'ailleurs qui n'ont surtout pas encore
été exposées par skype peuvent se
retrouver sur mon projet quelle que soit
l'origine de ces voix il personnellement
nationale y compris du parti communiste
et compris du front national y compris
du parti communiste c'est cette
ambiguïté qui conduit certains proches à
prendre leurs distances pendant neuf
mois le maire de saint-etienne a soutenu
cheikh le million aujourd'hui
il a rejoint les rangs de l'udf charles
millon a fait le choix d'accepter les
voix du front national je pense que le
plus mauvais choix qu'ils puissent faire
parce que il y a encore une fois un
gouffre entre les programmes du front
national les convictions de front
national et celle de l'alliance udf rpr
au sein de la droite parlementaire
certains rêvent encore d'un retrait du
candidat millau en cours de ce scrutin
mais ce soir l'ancien président la firme
il ira jusqu'au bout et pour les
élections européennes philippe de
villiers annoncé ce matin qu'il
entrerait en campagne le 18 janvier et
le président du mouvement pour la france
s'est adressé un charles pasqua pour
l'inviter à le rejoindre
quand charles aura finissant son marché
aux aromates de gauche et qu'il en a
trouvé dans son caddie que des deuxièmes
couteaux des troisièmes boireau nous lui
disons dès aujourd'hui charles garde
toujours une soupe à la maison
à paris trois plaintes dont deux pour
crimes contre l'humanité ont été
déposées auprès des autorités
judiciaires visant le chef de l'état
cubain fidel castro
les plaignants sont des ressortissants
cubains installés en france il utilise
ainsi ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
jurisprudence pinochet aux états unis à
washington c'était la rentrée officielle
du sénat dès demain ou peut-être même
avant devrait savoir s'il y aura bien un
procès du président clinton au sénat est
donc un vote des sénateurs pour ou
contre extradition il semble que des
tractations soient toujours en cours
pour éviter un procès est sanctionné le
président des états unis d'un blâme pour
parjure bien sûr la sphère clinton
lewinsky occupe la plus large part des
médias américains mais le conflit qui
semble en voie de s'achever ce soir dans
le monde du basket préoccupe tout aussi
largement le public américain il faut
savoir que les joueurs du championnat
américain de basket ball sont en grève
depuis 191 jours une grève pour une
affaire de gros sous et de très gros
contrats
mais le syndicat des joueurs et les
propriétaires des clubs seraient
parvenus il ya quelques heures un accord
qui permettrait de sauver la saison de
basket aux états unis explications avec
le reportage de notre correspondant à
new york dominique derda avec et de leur
père un c'était aujourd'hui ou jamais la
réunion de la dernière chance quand les
joueurs de basketball professionnel
américain se retrouve à new york ce
matin ils savent que s'ils ne
parviennent pas à un accord avec les
propriétaires de clubs la saison sera
purement et simplement annulé oui moi
j'ai envie de recommencer à jouer là
vous savez je perds sur tous les
tableaux tout le monde perd de l'argent
dans ces territoires
c'est fatiguant à la longue et je suis
sûr que la plupart des gars pensent
comme moi il faut qu'on arrive à trouver
un terrain d'entente
depuis plus de 6 mois aucun de ceux que
leurs supporters considèrent comme des
dieux vivants n'a touché un ballon
aucun non plus n'a touché un centime la
grève évidemment est une histoire de
très grosses ou ses joueurs gagnent en
moyenne 15 millions de francs par an
leurs salaires représentent 57 % du
budget annuel du basket professionnel
aux états unis
c'est trop pour les dirigeants de la
toute puissante nba
les joueurs il faut le reconnaître
mérite des biens payés ils nous offrent
un formidable spectacle et la nba ne
remet pas cela en cause du tout
financièrement la ligue se porte bien le
problème c'est simplement une question
de partage des revenus du basket
les propriétaires voudraient que ce soit
plutôt 50/50 or ces dernières années les
salaires des joueurs ont largement
dépassé cette limite le basket
professionnel aux états unis entre les
droits de retransmission les sponsors
les produits dérivés c'est un pactole de
2 milliards de dollars 12 milliards de
francs par an en acceptant ce matin de
voir baisser de 2 ou 3 % leurs revenus
les joueurs perdent est une petite
fortune mais il sauve in extremis une
saison de basket qui n'avait pas même
commencer leurs fans peuvent donc se
réjouir
dès la première semaine de février les
matches vont reprendre les dieux du
lancer franc ont parfois la grosse tête
mais ils ont aussi les pieds sur terre
en grande bretagne le système de santé
plus particulièrement les hôpitaux
publics connaissent de très graves
difficultés ces derniers jours une
épidémie de grippe très violente révèle
un encombrement des hôpitaux un manque
d'argent et d'infirmières les directeurs
des hôpitaux publics anglais utilisent
tous les moyens même les moins dignes
pour pallier leurs difficultés
reportage etienne énarque avec stand
renault
l'histoire est hallucinante mais elle
est révélatrice face à l'afflux de
malades au nombre élevé de décès et à
cause d'une morgue exigu cet hôpital a
décidé d'installer provisoirement sur
son parking ce camion frigorifique
initiative sordide que l'hôpital tente
de justifier
complètement débordés et nous avons
pensé que ce camion était le meilleur
moyen pour nous adapter et rapidement à
cette situation exceptionnelle pour moi
les couloirs des hôpitaux sont
transformées en salles d'urgence
il n'y a plus assez de chambres avec
l'épidémie de grippe qui touche surtout
le nord de l'angleterre
le fragile système de santé britannique
va si certains malades ont dû attendre
jusqu'à plus de 19 heures avant de
pouvoir être ausculté les malades ici
ont tous des problèmes de respiration de
bronchite d'asthme et le prochain on
peut en demander trop aux personnels de
la maison des médecins et des
infirmières de l'hôpital sont déjà la
limite de ce qui se passe c'est l'autre
versant du problème une pénurie sans
précédent d'infirmières dans les
hôpitaux publics mal payés travaillant
dans des conditions difficiles
elles se tournent vers le privé ou
changent de métier 8000 postes
d'infirmières sont à pourvoir à ce jour
en grande bretagne c'est trop de
responsabilités pour des gens vous
gagnez mieux votre vie si vous êtes un
conducteur de train en début de carrière
plutôt qu'une infirmière responsable de
20 malades
du coup les hôpitaux se tourner vers
l'étranger pour recruter des dizaine
d'infirmiers et d'infirmières philippins
sont arrivés ces derniers mois en
grande-bretagne
un bon niveau d'anglais une bonne
formation et le fait qu'ils acceptent
les salaires proposés en font des
candidats particulièrement apprécié mais
le système de santé britannique est un
grand malade à qui les thérapies
ponctuelles ne pourront pas suffi en
iran le gouvernement de téhéran en
reconnaît l'implication de certains de
ses agents des services secrets dans la
série d'assassinats commis contre des
intellectuels cinq personnes avaient été
tuées à la fin la dernière à téhéran
intellectuels libéraux et opposants
nationalistes et puis en sierra leone
les affrontements entre forces
gouvernementales et rebelles sont tourné
en faveur de ces derniers qui auraient
pris le contrôle de la présidence dans
le centre ville de freetown la capitale
de sierra leone en corse deux attentats
ont été commis la nuit dernière
injection contre l' agence de
développement économique de la corse et
l'autre à ghisonaccia en haute-corse
détruisant les locaux de la direction
départementale de l'équipement et de l'
agence de tourisme corse les dégâts
matériels sont importants deux personnes
ont été légèrement blessées
mais aucune revendication n'était laissé
sur le lieu des attentats
le tribunal correctionnel de paris a
condamné à 5 ans de prison le
photographe jean pierre bourgeois
principal accusé dans la sphère du
réseau de proxénétisme de luxe pour
prince arabe hommes d'affaires et
vedettes du show biz
peut-on rire de tout à cette question
pierre desproges répondait dans son
temps oui mais pas avec n'importe qui
patrick timsit était accusé d'avoir ri
des personnes trisomiques
à la demande du père d'un jeune homme
trisomique qui devait comparaître en
justice aujourd'hui finalement patrick
timsit et le plaignant sont tombés
d'accord pour créer ensemble une
association destinée à lutter contre
l'exclusion dont souffrent les
trisomiques compte rendu de cette
journée dominique verdeilhan et didier
rancoeur on se croirait au festival de
cannes patrick timsit et bien sûr des
marches
mais ce sont celles du palais de justice
de paris à ses côtés pascal duquenne qui
avait joué dans le film le huitième jour
et robert forest le père d'un jeune
trisomique 21
il y à quelques minutes encore ils
s'affrontaient à la barre à la fin du
procès ils se sont réconciliés
trois heures plus tôt on ne sourit guère
de nombreux trisomiques 21 accompagnés
de leurs parents venaient demander
réparation à patrick timsit objet du
délit un sketch de 1992 intitulée le
chirurgien mécaniciens et une phrase de
trop dans la bouche de l'humoriste le
mongolien je cite c'est comme la
crevette rose tout est bon sauf chat est
une phrase que patrick lui aussi à
retirer de chants sketches par la suite
sept ans plus tard la sphère vient
devant les tribunaux patrick timsit
plaide je suis désolé d'avoir fait du
mal
france non seulement
et part en afrique ici et les
trisomiques 21 6 et qu'on allait mettre
notre énergie ailleurs et ensemble en
réponse
robert forêt retire sa plainte et
annonce la création d'une association
mal compris peut-être qui sait
certainement mal exprimé pour le dire
aussi
et puis bon ben il a fait ses plus bas
des excuses et à la suite de ça plutôt
que de continuer un combat l'un contre
l'autre il vaut mieux qu'on s'unisse
tous les deux pour soit créée une
association durant près d'une heure et
demie les avocats des deux parties
avaient plaidé sur le thème peut-on rire
de tout de rire qui blessent d'un côté
le rire qui dénonce de l'autre il a
suffi de quelques regards quelques
phrases échangées entre un père et un
artiste pour stopper la machine
judiciaire transformant les juges et les
trisomiques en simple témoin d'une
inattendue réconciliation sport
automobile présentation d'une nouvelle
équipe de formule 1 pour la saison 99 la
british american racing la barbe et ar
l'un des deux pilotes et le canadien
jacques villeneuve et la voiture est
équipée de moteurs renault mecachrome
et puis le dakar c'était la sixième
étape aujourd'hui toujours disputée en
mauritanie
l'allemande jutta kleinschmidt est resté
en sable est prisonnière du désert de
perdre sa première place au classement
général il ya maintenant tet2 buggy
celle de josé maria servia et du
français jean louis schlesser en tête du
classement général de ce dakar
pourquoi pas moi c'est un film à partir
d'aujourd'hui sur les écrans de cinéma
c'est le premier film de stéphane giusti
c'est une comédie une comédie sur la
tolérance et le respect des autres même
s'ils choisissent d'avoir une sexualité
différente
principal argument de ce film que nous
allons évoquer avec nos invités julie
gayet johnny hallyday comment annoncer à
ses parents que l'on est homosexuel
reportage stéphane haumant et frédéric
basket c'est que je vous demandais tout
ce que vous faites ici vous allez vite
comprendre non des filles au bord de la
crise de nerfs un repas de famille qui
tourne au jeu de la vérité
et un aveu pas facile à faire aux
parents on est belle on est fiers on est
lesbienne parce que pour des enfants
c'est peut-être une peur de faire de la
paix moussa c'est l'homosexualité ça
pourrait être autre chose mais mais
c'est peut-être la peur aussi de briser
un rêve quand les parents imaginent
également aux pères à taureaux avec une
fille boudou
moi aussi j'aime les filles auxquelles
ni pourquoi pas moi c'est [ __ ] douce
plus gazon maudit double vie et conflits
de générations c'est une comédie légère
qui pose avec le sourire quelques
questions intimes en faisant sienne je
suis demandé mais qu'est ce que je
penserais si mon frère était homosexuel
et qu'est ce que mes parents pensent
récit moi j'étais lesbienne et qu'est ce
qui arriverait si mon père qui était la
mère et que c'était pour un mec et je
suis rendu compte que j'étais pas aussi
ouverte que ça et ça m'a aidé à ouvrir
mon esprit un peu plus pour son premier
film stéphane giusti aborde de front un
thème rarement traité au cinéma
l'homosexualité féminine
il ya seulement dix ans le pari aurait
semblé injouable mais aujourd'hui les
temps ont changé les comédiens s'amusent
sans complexe de leurs personnages
victimes
toi tu me les brise attention big jim sa
prochaine mission démanteler un réseau
de queen intégristes des histoires de
couples des histoires d'amour tout
simplement en s'embrassant à la ligue
bourinos alors pourquoi pas moi ne
cherche pas à choquer si le film milite
c'est seulement pour davantage de
tolérance
c'était un baiser de plus oui vous étiez
posez vous la question avoir comme jay
carney non mais j'aurais pu me la pole à
poser mais c'est vrai que dans ma
famille on parle de ça plus ouvertement
ou je sais pas c'était on se l'est
jamais vraiment posé mais on aurait
voilà j'ai pas un jour n'avait dit
commencer si on aime une fille ou un
garçon
mes parents me guy boucher quand vous
êtes attiré par les filles ou par les
garçons quelque chose d'assez naturel
mais je me suis jamais posé la question
j'ai tout de suite été attiré par les
garçons quand vous avez un bon d'accord
vous avez lu le scénario
quelle a été votre première réaction
génial c'est la première fois qu'on
parle de l'homosexualité féminine comme
ça beaucoup plus d'ailleurs c'est les
femmes ont le rôle majeur quand même
dans ce film y tellement puisqu'elle est
d'habitude c'est toujours jeu par la
cage aux folles beaucoup dans les films
sur l'homosexualité les garçons qui ont
d'ailleurs toujours c'est traire les
grandes folles et tout ça c'est ou alors
c'est des films très sérieux beaucoup
plus réaliste et là c'est un mélange des
deux mais ça je trouvais ça vient je me
suis dit enfin un film différent
alors on vous dit l'un des pères sera
johnny hallyday alors vous réagissez
comme ans parce que moi je suis la
génération c ses idoles c'est comment
vous vous êtes retrouvé à la rue
enfin c'est comme quand vous êtes un peu
comme aujourd'hui le trac c'est vraiment
moi tu es puis après c'était mon père
quoi voilà c'était le comédien et on
était c'est un bonheur un bonheur
mais c'est vrai que je n'étais que quand
on vous annonce que non mais quoi passer
film surtout bon
je pense que ça se voit en suivant on
s'est vraiment beaucoup marré quoi ouais
pendant le tournage pendant le tournage
hmm hmm hmm mort en retournant je veux
dire enfin sur le son plateau c'était un
bonheur de se retrouver tous ensemble
mais vous êtes complètement à contre
emploi quand même là dedans c'est un
symbole de virilité
je suis content que stéphane mais
proposé ce rôle parce que moi je voulais
je voulais absolument un rôle à contre
emploi
je voulais pas faire un retour au cinéma
j'ai fait pas mal de films un retour au
cinéma être employé comme j'ai été
employé c'est-à-dire fairly phrase
qu'est ce que les gens pensent que je
suis en réalité dans la vie c'est à dire
john ellis tout simplement pour être
crédible quand on a un nom connu dans un
autre métier
quoique très proches sont andré comme
elias est très proche mais quand même
chanteur c'est difficile sereins les
crampons qu'odette crédible quand on a
un autre personnage à jouer donc la
seule façon d'être crédible c'est de
faire quelque chose de complètement
différent de faire un rôle à contre
emploi
enfin vous êtes le père a eu peut-être
le plus compréhensif le plus sympa que
dans tout ça et pourtant le plus macho
puisque je suis cadre elle adore après
sur le retour et et mais comme j'aime
profondément ma vie juste et que j'aime
profondément et que je cherche à la
comprendre jeu disons que la tolérance
bien avec ça il est ce qu'on a voulu je
pense que stéphane surtout notre maître
laurence elle a voulu montrer dans ce
film c'est là c'est un film sur l'amour
et la tolérance
mais honnêtement il ya 20 ans il ya
trente ans n'aurait jamais pu faire ce
genre de fille la tolérance le respect à
nous balancer il y avait les tabous il y
avait tabou qui se sont quand même
effondré début depuis 20 ans 30 ans
c'est vrai que on n'aurait jamais pu
faire un film sur l'homosexualité
homme ou femme et
comme ça même même en rigolant comme
aujourd'hui vous avez progressé mais dit
il faut pas oublier une chose c'est à
hatem sérieux elle est traitée en
comédie corps mais vous même
personnellement l'homme vous avez
progressé dans la tolérance à l'égard
d'une sexualité où j'ai beaucoup d'avis
qu'ils sont homos femmes qui sont
remboursés qu suel moi ça ne me dérange
pas parce que je sens les gens les plus
les gens les plus touchants et en
général les gens les plus cordiales et
ce sont les gens qui sont les plus
sincères
julie gayet qui fait la leçon vous tiré
de ses personnages vous êtes plusieurs
femmes à assumer votre sexualité à le
dire ouvertement et à le dire dans une
vraie joie comme un bon il ya un petit
peu de larmes mais d'une vraie solution
en haleine en tout cas de l'assumer en
fait pas vraiment je pense que c'est ça
reste et eva c'est quand même une
dragueuse ici elle drague comme ça vous
verrez dans la république c'est parce
qu'il doit y avoir quelque chose d'un
peu et je pense que c'est ça le dire à
ses parents est vraiment assumer ça
c'était un truc à moi je pense que c'est
important c'est pas facile évident donc
en fait c'est elle et touchant pour moi
je sais ce que j'aime mon succès si
c'est vrai c'est une comédie vraiment et
en même temps on se sent que voilà c'est
pas facile
pourquoi ce qui est important de jeu qui
est important c'est que pour un acteur
de jouer un rôle d'homosexuel que soient
vos femmes quand on l'est pas surtout
c'est de jouer et c'est pas jouer la
folk malouen feu traditionnelles comme
il ya comme on voit des fois des clichés
dans des films qui sont même à la limite
ça frise le ridicule
c'est ça qui est important comme on
m'aime un homosexuel un vrai de jouer un
rôle
dans l'homme qu'il n'y ait pas qu'il
n'est pas nouveau mot sexuelle c'est ça
d'être avec quelqu'un d'autre
mergia vous êtes partis les parfaites
naturel quand vous lui annoncer il est
là où on va mais il faut qu'elle arrive
là ainsi pour ceux ci ne sert donc
aujourd'hui sur les écrans je vais
revenir plus sérieusement parce que je
pense que vous êtes vous aussi touchée
par la mort de michel platini c'était
quelqu'un que vous est-il hibou et bien
sûr oui je ne connaissais pas
personnellement
malheureusement mais tout ce que je peux
dire c'est que dans le jazz et surtout
dans la musique
c'était un très grand musicien et il va
nous manquer à tous merci beaucoup à la
fin de ce journal je vous rappelle deux
informations entre concerne lionel
jospin qui a détaillé le programme
d'action de son gouvernement dans le
journal le monde et contre-attaqué face
aux initiatives les jean jacques chirac
et puis le fait que madame trautmann
vient de déclarer que la réforme de
l'audiovisuel est maintenu mais qu'il
n'y a pas de calendrier
la météo c'est dans quelques secondes
avec isabelle martinet puis à 20h55 la
voisine intelli chine les clean renault
et fanny cottençon 55 'journal explorant
supra suivi du bivouac du paris dakar et
du cerf de philippe lefait et puis pour
refermer cette édition en hommage à
michel petrucciani mort aujourd'hui à
new york
je vous propose de l'écouter c'était en
février 98 sur france 2 dans le cercle
des arts de frédéric mitterrand michel
petrucciani interprétait brasillach à
demain 20 heures dont soir merci
oui
là
et
ouais